jimena le echo un vistazo a la siguiente
sucesión 0 38 15 24 35 tras mirarla por
un rato noto que cada número era uno
menos que un cuadrado perfecto recuerden
un cuadrado perfecto simplemente es un
número de la forma n al cuadrado es un
entero que es simplemente otro entero
elevado al cuadrado y conjeturó que el
enésimo número en la sucesión era n al
cuadrado menos 1
conjeturó esa palabra suena muy
rimbombante pero que significa
conjeturar conjeturar significa hacer
una predicción sobre lo que va a pasar
que es concordante con los hechos a los
que tienes acceso ok por ejemplo en este
caso parece que 0 es 1 al cuadrado menos
13 2 al cuadrado que es 4 menos 18 es 3
al cuadrado menos 1 que serían 9 menos
18 y así sucesivamente por lo tanto hay
un patrón y podemos hacer una predicción
pero no sabemos si esa predicción va a
ser verdad es
diferencia entre una conjetura y una
prueba que en este caso no sabemos si el
patrón va a continuar parecería que el
próximo término si sería veamos este
sería el sexto término así que el
séptimo debería ser siete al 449
parecería que el séptimo término va a
ser 48 49 menos 1 pero no podemos
asegurarlo igual y el patrón cambia
repentinamente que tal que aquí sigue
algo raro como un 75 o un 415 no lo
sabemos no podemos asegurar que eso no
pasa por lo tanto solo podemos
conjeturar uso jimena razonamiento
inductivo explica tu respuesta pues sí
sí uso el razonamiento inductivo y es
precisamente por lo que estábamos
diciendo es ese es el motivo por el cual
sólo puede conjeturar la respuesta
jimena observó un patrón en los números
se dio cuenta que 0 era 1 al cuadrado
menos 13 era 2 al cuadrado menos 18 era
3 al cuadrado menos 115 era 4 al
cuadrado menos 124 5 al cuadrado menos
135 es 6 al cuadrado menos 1 entonces
ella propone
la situación n al cuadrado menos 1 y
como esto es coherente con lo que sabe
de antes esto se vale para esta
situación para esta sucesión entonces
eso es precisamente razonamiento
inductivo tomar un patrón presente en
los datos a los que tienes acceso y
extrapolarlo continuarlo hacia el futuro
así que si si uso razonamiento inductivo